Frist we will discuss active power. The active
power can be computed as one half of the
total capacitance of the circuit, where the capacitance
can be seen as roughly proportional to chip area.
So, larger chips will have more of this.
The next factor is voltage square. This is the
power supply voltage. The higher the power supply
voltage, the higher the power is. And this relationship
is quadratic. So, doubling of the power supply
voltage will actually quadruple the power. The next
factor is clock frequency. This is the gigahertz
number that you normally see on a processor
specification. And finally, the alpha is the activity
factor. Without this alpha, we are assuming that
the processor is constantly switching every clock cycle
all of it's transistors. So, alpha really says that,
for example, only 10% of the process transistors
are actually active in any give clock cycle.
Now, let's see what happens to power, if,
after two years, we reduce the size of the
processor to one half of what it was,
because of technology improvement. The new capacitance is
half of what it was for one processor.
However, because we want to build a more powerful processor,
we put two of them on the chip. So, the
C new really is equal to C old. Let's say
that the voltage and the frequency stay the same, and
let's say that it's still the same processor design, so
the same percentage of transistors are active. That means really
that the active power is relatively unchanged if we do
this. What we have is effectively a processor that consumes
the same amount of power, but it does have twice
the number of cores that it had before,
so it's, it's actually twice its capable computationally,
because each of those cores is still operating
at the same frequency before. And it's really a
very similar to the old core. In reality,
smaller transistors are going to be faster, so we
can increase the clock frequency of the processor
too. So, let's say that the new clock frequency
is 25% higher than the old one. That increases the power consumed. So, it's
now twice as fast, because of the
number of cores. Another 25% improvement because of
this. But the overall power consumption is
now higher. Smaller transistors, however, may let
us lower the power supply voltage while
maintaining the same speed. So, let's say that
the new power supply voltage is equal to
0.8 of the old power supply voltage. That
allows us to have a significantly lower power
consumption because of this square relationship. So 0.8 squared
is 0.64. If we put these two together,
we can get something like the voltage. We don't
lower it as much, because if we did,
then we couldn't also increase the frequency, so we
lower it only a little bit. The frequency, we
can not increase it as much, because if we did,
we would have to keep the same power supply voltage
as before, so let's say we only increase the frequency
by a factor of 1.1. If you now apply this
equation, we get that the new power is about 90%
of the old power. So, what we got is now,
we have a chip that is having two cores instead
of one. It has a lower power supply voltage,
but a higher frequency. So, each of these cores is
10% faster than the one used to be. And
yet, we have lowered power consumption. This is why it's
so important for active power to have the technology
improvement to reduce the size of transistors. And we also
have to realize that in order to get power
improvements, we really, really, really need to lower the voltage.